I broke it once you broke it it's not
meant for uh humans
but it could hang so many thousands of
clothes
[Music]
so the US government won't show up just
slapped three McDonald's franchises in
Kentucky with more than 200 000 in fines
why because they sorry
no good no joke go ahead uh we all get
one we all go all right they did it in
Kentucky right I feel like the Kentucky
Fried Chicken mob is behind this and
they're just like
all right you [__] McDonald's
trying to move into my territory well
guess what I'm gonna collude with my
government and we're gonna [__] you guys
up and that's what happened yep you got
nothing is that what happened how how
spot-on was it let's keep doing uh no no
damn it man see that's what I said fine
I'll eat another pastry then is it
because the government that part is so
cool dude what's the best part all right
it's because the government wanted like
the the frozen yogurt and then but then
McDonald's like sorry the machines are
broken and then they did a [__] the
launch an investigation oh what's really
going on this is [__] yeah
they don't want to sell the McFlurries
those pieces of [__] is this because of
what happened with Bud Light no no you
know what I noticed what when I'm
tasting something I can't hear anything
can we switch to the news to whatever
this is about
we just give Bart different colors this
tastes really good I don't even know
I didn't say anything
no taste buds oh my God okay uh so I'll
carry on as if that didn't happen
um
what they had found in an investigation
was that these McDonald's were employing
miners including a 10 year old boy who
was a alleged or illegally made to work
until 2 A.M and who was allowed to
operate a deep fryer and they weren't
getting paid okay you know what that is
he's [__] 10 years old you know what
that is
that's hustle culture bro
these kids are Tick Tock watching Gary
going places dude you know what I'll
work and I don't even need to get paid
I'm on the wake up Ryan two kids
standing in a [__] big trench coat
on top of each other they're like hey
add it together we're 20 right yeah dude
you know we stand on the box to use the
fryer the fryer is like deep in there
yeah yeah it's a deep fryer yeah is the
franchise owned by an Asian family and
they're making the Asian kids do [__] oh
yeah because it does teach them
character it can talk it's an epic
background of the owners but no I don't
think they're Asians why people say
family uh why people say child labor
Asian people say family business yes you
know I'm kind of I'm kind of all for
child labor a little bit I think little
kids can provide better say that facing
the camera I'm for child labor a little
bit vote poor Nick hey when you were 10
did you help out at your parents
absolutely but isn't that the cutest
nice way to say it like [__] four
students didn't get to play with
steaming machine like a hot steaming
what were your jobs at 10 I wasn't I
wasn't allowed to operate crazy
Machinery uh I was allowed to like put
stuff in the machine you know what I
mean like take the clothes or take it
out but they wouldn't let me push all
the buttons and stuff like that when I
was young can you explain real quick
when what did what how did dry cleaners
clean clothes yeah
that's actually a good question yeah why
is it because I've always been dry
cleaner did they only throw it in the
dryer because it's not it's uh it's more
like heat cleaning it's not actually uh
like water cleaning
um but how do you get a stain out it's
like yeah you just take a blow dryer and
they melt off the chocolate yeah yeah
it's just back there with a bunch of
cotton you know you're also you're also
asking like the kid who was there who
wasn't operating machine so I don't
really have the best answers for you
what I do know is the delivery routes
that my parents would have to take in
the schedule and stuff and I knew how to
classify the clothes and I knew how to
bag and hang them up and operate with
the customers oh so everything but the
actual I wasn't allowed to do the
machines I was allowed to steam press
them I wasn't allowed to use the actual
washers I wasn't allowed to do anything
I had major Machinery I see because
they're like our Sun's more like a
secretary not like a real man so then we
can't have him do all the hard labor
yeah and did they speak slowly to you
ever like were they speaking slow
just to make sure that you understood
what they were saying
sounds like my parents
how do you categorize it you know the
thing where they go you give them your
ticket and go it's like Dewey decimals
oh yeah alphabetical yeah those are just
numbers so how do they know you're on
the number and then when you and when
you take when you put the clothes on the
rack with the number you write that
number on the ticket you rip that ticket
in half you give that ticket back to the
person so you they just go like this and
they look for 19 and come back down yeah
because numbers are in numeric order oh
you're saying it's not efficient huh
dude I never wore I never wore nice
clothes or anything like that anything
cool so I remember like moving out on my
own well until recently but I'm just dry
cleaning moving out on my own whenever I
saw dry cleaners I was like what a bunch
of Chumps I was like are you just just
use your washer dryer you [__] idiots
like I had no idea why people did that
yeah like certain clothes like a vanity
thing what's the main thing that people
would bring together well things like
suits blouses dresses stuff like that
you know wedding dresses wedding dresses
you always had to Outsource right but
yeah suits were huge and you know we're
talking about like the 90s right so like
everybody who's in the regular working
class is always wearing some sort of
like collar or button-up or all of my
mom's clothes had [__] shoulder pads
in it exactly dry clean yeah those are
all dry clean clothes did you guys have
the rotating electronic rack two of them
did you play with them as a kid
absolutely did you hang on them like a
[__] zip lines wanted I broke it once
you broke it it's not meant for uh
humans
but it could hang so many thousands of
clothes all dispersed every single one
that actually hangs is really just a
light amount of weight I see but it's
all in one big you must have gotten in
big big trouble for that what I did
enjoy though was that we had a sign that
legally said any clothes left here after
90 days like we have no liability over
so there'll be times where my ass would
just like check the clothes after it's
been like 90 days I would have to like
go down the rack and see if something's
been gone for over three months and
technically how often backed it you ever
hide something
90 days sounds like a long time it does
90 days is a long time you imagine
dropping off your dry cleaning not
picking up for three months on top I've
done that before I got a party who would
do that I would have probably do that
because sometimes you go okay cool I'll
come back in a week or two and then
obviously oh [__] I have that like trip
I gotta take and you go and then you
come back and they're like oh back in
the day they would call like you'd have
a list of people and then you would call
them and see where they're at we would
only call our customers that were like
regular customers uh we wanted to talk
about one time I was about to go to a
wedding ring and I was like Hey so tell
me if this is if this is real I was like
hey I need this dry clean like right now
and they're like we can't do you got to
give us like time and I was like this is
[__]
I was like I need this like have you
heard people say that is that really is
that really true extra for a rush dry
clean but you still got to give them 24
hours you know what I [__] hate the
one hour photo places like I'll come
back on Tuesday like it says one hour
what the [__] what's with that yeah
that's a scam explain that yeah explain
that is it because it only takes an hour
for you to go in and take pictures
it's like it is one hour you waited here
for 30 minutes I collected your film
another 15 minutes transactions an hour
did nobody else have to help their
parents when they were young no my
parents I Was the janitor of my dad's
business I was like cleaning [__]
toilets and [__] that's child labor
mine's just family business his is child
labor oh I don't think I was allowed on
my mom our parents business yeah was she
making a stained glass toast
staying closer that's her hobby my mom
worked at like a corporate building my
dad worked at a casino I can't be
dealing cars and [__]
I had to watch a movie without no audio
and make horse sounds yeah I'm [__]
dope dude that's a fun job
that sounds like a dad just trying to
keep you occupied like you got a dad
yeah I'm recording son go ahead he's
like rub those uh two slices of lettuce
together this is eight hours of this
it's like a coal miner dude I feel so
bad for you that's crazy did you have
any other employees at your dry cleaners
besides your family oh yeah for sure so
they were other kids no no not kids come
on now does your sister get the same
duties yeah she had the same dude she
probably had more huh because she's
older no I think we have the exact same
amount I think that she was just better
at things because she was older and
smarter so that they just trusted me
less but also your parents are telling
you how dumb you are though
that's a big part of it so you're just
like I'm bad at this so you're like your
kid you know
I'll I'll definitely get in trouble
what's the most what's the most
expensive thing that you guys have at
dry clean business
uh well I'll tell you this this is this
is a particular random incidence right
um my parents actually got into a
lawsuit with their landlord uh because
one he wanted to oust them from the from
the compost yeah in order to like get
like just a new tenant because we've
been there for a long period of time and
you know they want to raise the raise
the rent stuff like that so then
he got the city to come in and then test
the ground underneath and found that
they were like quote-unquote leaked
chemicals from the dry cleaning you know
like dry cleaning chemicals can go into
the ground or whatever because like a
small amount was like traced in the
ground we got into a lawsuit for it had
to settle so my parents got [__] damn
financially uh and then we also had to
leave the property and this is the only
time my dad's a really civil nice guy
that's the only time I've ever seen him
like have
like hate towards another human being
yeah for sure like literally saving when
I'm a kid to literally say things like I
wish I could if I just saw him in the
street I would hit him with my car yeah
homicidal thoughts dude because going
through the stress of a lawsuit like
that oh man I think I'd murder someone
I'd want immerse and I never got it
until until the pandemic and I felt the
same way about our land yeah oh [__]
[__] these people
foreign